en fait il y avait 13 personnes en gros
13 avocats juge après comme ça avec une
autorité de poursuite qui était le
méchant de l'histoire un peu le
procureur quoi
et effectivement déjà première incidence
en arrivant c'est qu'on a on nous dit ok
où il y a du public mais vous ne pourrez
pas accueillir plus de 30 personnes ça
c'est pas possible déjà il y a un droit
c'est soit audience et public soit elle
l'est pas mais à partir du moment où je
demande qu'elle soit publique le public
qui est là il y avait une grande salle
dans laquelle le public pouvait être
présent on a demandé on a dû exiger avec
force que le public puisse être présent
premier élément ensuite pendant ça il
faut bien comprendre de quoi on parle
pendant 6 heures si 7h ou à 5h on a
discuté de mes passages sur TPMP et de
mes tweets c'est tout parce que là il y
a un truc comme qui circule c'est que
des clients ce serait plein ça c'est
faux j'ai un moment donné je sais plus
comment dire que c'est faux c'est
tellement faux que j'en étais obligé
hier soir à France Info d'envoyer la
réputation non regardez regardez et donc
parce que l'ordre joue un jeu un peu un
peu double d'un côté il me juge pour des
tweets et des propos sur TPMP mais de
l'autre il faut circuler la rumeur que
ce serait bien plus grave que ça ça
c'est pas normal d'accord donc c'est
faux et donc est-ce que c'est pour tes
positions sur le vaccin et cetera je
crois qu'on est dans un procès purement
politique d'accord il faut pas faut pas
chercher il y a deux éléments il y a un
procès à côté politique et de l'autre
fois que ça aussi un procès de société
vous avez reçu ici Sergueï
qui a été jeté de de LCI
ou le même pas laissé la possibilité de
s'expliquer et il s'est fait directement
renvoyer pour des propos on voit bien
qu'à un moment donné on a basculé dans
une société qui accepte plus cette
notion de liberté d'expression et c'est
d'autant plus curieux si tu veux qu'on a
alors des avocats qui a pas arrêté de
proclamer je suis Charlie et ben
maintenant on sait qu'ils sont Charlie
mais pas des visions manifestement alors
pas tout à fait pareil
la liberté non
rien qui a défendu Charlie a dit la
liberté d'expression c'est le sang qui
coule dans les veines de la démocratie
à partir du moment où tu viens pardon
vous venez effectivement
empêcher un avocat de parler au sens où
effectivement vous le poursuivez pour
ses propos hors prêts
naturellement
avoir été poursuivi par l'Ordre des
avocats pour outrance j'en sais rien en
premier
c'est intéressant c'est pour tes
participations à TPMP
parce que c'est quoi alors que c'est
parce que en fait ce qui me reproche ce
qu'on me reproche c'est deux choses
c'est derrière ma vulgarité soyons bien
clair c'est la vulgarité de l'émission
qu'on reproche c'est le format de
l'émission mais c'est absolument évident
puisque l'émission qu'on a là elle est
absolument pas celle qu'on a sur LCP ou
sur BFM et que naturellement quand je
m'exprime sur BFM peu importe
ça c'est clair
tu reçois pas des des messages des SMS
quand tu passes sur LCP non mais soyons
bien d'accord
ici ce que j'aime c'est précisément la
liberté de débats exactement ouais viens
c'est à moi qui disait ça qui disait que
TPMP le digne héritier de droit de
réponse à l'époque par par Michel
polnareck c'est exactement ça je veux
dire on va arrêter de tout le temps
essayer d'être absolument poli tout le
temps et puis il y a un autre paramètre
je croyais qu'on était en guerre alors
si on est en guerre utilisant un langage
de guerre enfin je veux dire mais
arrêtons de faire la guerre avec des
fleurs enfin ça ça marche pas cette
histoire on va pas faire de la guerre
avec
Fabrice qu'est-ce qui te reproché au
niveau de TPMP donc toi pour toi le nerf
de la guerre c'est tes tweet et TPMP ah
c'est pas pour moi c'est c'est ce qui
m'est reproché là pour moi on m'a
expliqué que c'était indigne que ma
façon de m'exprimer est indigne en ce
que elle est impétueuse vulgaire ce qui
m’amuse en fait je suis pas d'accord
alors je vais te dire un truc tu sais de
qui on disait qu'il était vulgaire de
Victor Hugo Victor Hugo on disait de
Victor Hugo qui a été vulgaire et tu
sais pourquoi parce qu'il était peuple
c'est Hugo de Lançon qui était historien
de littérature qui disait qu'il était
peuple et voilà ce que on pourrait dire
que Victor Hugo tu es le premier gilet
jaune histoire
et donc c'est intéressant parce que il
faut quand même noter un truc c'est ce
que j'ai dit j'ai dit qu'effectivement à
un moment donné c'est on a eu le procès
de Flaubert on a eu un procès de
Baudelaire c'est toujours une époque en
fait
quand même Fabrice que entre j'accuse et
ce que vous avez dit sur sur le plateau
de TPMP il y a quand même un gap
excusez-moi vous vous êtes d'accord avec
la sanction parce qu'il va nous dans la
sanction dans un instant moi je suis
d'accord ou pas d'accord avec la
sanction qu'il soit content
je veux dire ce qu'ils ont dit les juges
comme ça je le dis aussi nous c'est ce
qui prône Fabrice c'est la liberté
d'expression qui soit avocat il y a
plein d'avocats qui viennent dans
l'émission voilà donc même titre que
d'autres avocats il est convoqué par
l'ordre de nom mais avocats
parce qu'il est venu
sur un point quand même est-ce que c'est
moi qui ai dit je voulais emmerder une
nouvelle est-ce que je l'ai dit ici
est-ce que j'ai dit on les aura ces
connards qui a dit ça qui a dit ça
et qu'est-ce qui a dit Castaner quand on
a dit enfin il est vulgaire le Président
il parle comme les Français mais
j'entends ce que donc alors on m'a
expliqué ce matin que parler comme les
Français avec un langage qui était un
langage finalement vulgaire c'était
mépriser les Français j'ai pris ce matin
que le Président de la République
méprise 60 millions de Français très
bien moi le président
parle comme les Français j'aime quand tu
parles comme les Français ce que je
disais la dernière fois c'est vrai qu'on
veut même des politiques qui parlent
comme les Français on veut des avocats
qui parlent comme les français si on
veut une télévision qui parle qui parle
à tous et bah allez sur France 5 ou sur
Arte
moi regardez vous serez plus tranquille
je ne suis pas d'accord avec les
politiques qui parlent comme les
Français parce qu'on a on m'a parlé de
Mélenchon la dernière fois qui parlait
comme les Français et moi perso ça me
choque mais après que ce soit un avocat
oui pourquoi pas parce que un avocat il
est là pour défendre le peuple il le
fait pour moi je pense honnêtement
contrairement à ces politiques qui font
semblant d'être comme le peuple et qui
ne le sont pas moi je pense qu'un avocat
a le droit de parler comme le peuple ça
c'est sûr et puis autre chose
c'est un peu maintenant ce qui me
caractérise d'abord la passion je suis
un homme de passion ouais c'est vrai que
je suis un fruit engagé engagé jusqu'au
bout de ce que je suis je veux dire et
c'est ça qui me caractérise et que je
supporte pas on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec moi c'est génial de pas
être d'accord avec moi parce que c'est
ça qui nourrit la démocratie c'est le
débat le débat français souvent il y a
plein qui sont pas d'accord avec nous
c'est génial de pas être d'accord
je leur ai dit que le propre de la
démocratie c'était le débat franc vif
avec gilberté quand on frite mais c'est
super bien sûr est-ce que c'est comme ça
qu'on avance en fait vous là et il y a
un respect mutuel qui fait que on est
capable quand même dans ce plateau on
s'est engueuler plein de fois mais on
est quand même capable de se respecter
néanmoins je veux dire en n'étant pas
d'accord c'est ça le propre de la
démocratie en fait alors
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'ils t'ont dit
c'est quoi le délibéré alors il a été
requis contre moi trois mois
d'interdiction d'exercice plus 3 mois
3 mois
avec avec
10 ans et content et quand on lui ouais
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est à peu près ça ouais ok
c'est c'est
moi ferme maintenant
ça vous avez eu enchanté ça vous avez eu
vous avez on vous a requis ça parce que
vous êtes venus entre autres et mes
tweet ça veut dire que moi je vais
passer devant le tribunal
[Applaudissements]
j'avais pas une dame très messieurs
dames d'accord pour venir juger pendant
4 heures de mes tweets et mes passages
télé je rappelle quand même qu'on au
bord de la 3e guerre mondiale que
finalement les Français dans deux mois
vont cailler et ont peut-être plus avoir
à bouffer mais nous on se réunit pour
parler de mes tweets et de mes passages
tu les ok on peut faire ça oui de vos
clients non mais ça mes clients tout le
monde s'en foutent est-ce que le
problème si c'était pas que votre
visibilité qui était énorme ici du coup
rendez un peu votre profession de loyer
déloyale par rapport à vos confrères
parce que vous avez beaucoup plus
d'exposition du coup le problème c'est
pas le mien parce que vous veniez pour
parler pour défendre quelqu'un vous pour
parler des faits de société alors ça
c'est intéressant c'est exactement oui
c'est ce que je leur ai expliqué ce
matin parce que il y a un truc
extraordinaire c'est qu'on m'a dit dans
la citation que à la limite si mes
propos avec tes tenues en salle
d'audience ça va pas poser de problème
ah bah ça alors
effectivement donc j'ai le droit
concrètement d'être vulgaire face à un
magistrat il va être content de le
savoir quand même
il va être content la vérité c'est que
incontestablement il y a un peu de ça
soyons bien d'accord ma visibilité elle
pose un problème c'est clair mais moi
dans un instant fabrique j'aimerais
vraiment que tu nous dises ce qui s'est
dit parce que des mots il y a eu des
mots horrible je lui ai eu des mots
horrible voilà je le dis et tu vas aussi
réagir
d'exercices pendant 3 mois
dans un instant et vous allez me dire
s'il y en a qui sont d'accord avec les
sanctions qui ont été prises sur il ne
revient pas demain
il reviendront demain
est-ce que je peux y aller moi
je reviendrai pour te voir
quand tu seras calmé
parce qu'en fait comme comme il a dit
que quand on est là on peut aller en
prison
[Applaudissements]
ça dépend tu as déjà mangé des avocats
j'aime beaucoup les avocats mais c'est
triste qui vous arrive
je vous remettrai c'est vrai bah alors
pourquoi vous êtes là
[Applaudissements]
il y a Gabriel
c'est justement à réagi
chez c'est à vous c'est vrai regardez là
il y a un instant on a l'extrait
regardez ce qu'il dit et charlatan la
médecine il y a aussi les charlatans du
droit moi ce qui m'a frappé aussi dans
le rappel que vous avez fait c'est de
voir un certain nombre de médias de
radio de télévision qui lui ont donné
une tribune voilà parce qu'on parle
beaucoup on regarde beaucoup les réseaux
sociaux parfois certains médias ont
aussi un phénomène d'accélération en
donnant une tribune et en légitimement
quelque part certains personnages qui
ensuite gagnent de l'influence sur les
réseaux sociaux et le côté vu à la télé
s'il est passé sur un plateau c'est
quelque part que il est crédible souvent
c'est les mêmes qui disent par ailleurs
que ce qu'on voit à la télé dise
n'importe quoi mais je passe donc voilà
oui je pense que c'était important qu'il
puisse y avoir ces sanctions maintenant
je pense pas que ça n'empêchera de
continuer à raconter n'importe quoi à
peu près partout alors Fabrice donc vous
avez vu
c'était son boulot pendant quelques tant
que porte-parole donc raconter n'importe
quoi mais c'est comment on fait c'est de
quoi il parle au moins lui ça au moins
effectivement j'aurais dû le prendre
comme avocat parce que ne raconter
n'importe quoi c'est son boulot
et il sera toujours invité visio et les
autres ici c'est un espace de liberté il
y a toujours des contradicteurs il y a
toujours de la contradiction et au
contraire c'est le débat qui fait
avancer la politique de débat qui fait
avancer des idées on sait pas en mettant
des gens au placard qu'on va
fabriquer visio il représente un courant
de pensée il représente la couronne
pensée de nombreux français donc nous on
l'invite sur le plateau et on continuera
à inviter des gens qui ont toutes les
pensées sur ce plateau on invite autant
des gens du gouvernement on aura Gérald
Darmanin d'ailleurs merci à lui ministre
de l'Intérieur ce sera avec nous pour le
premier face à Baba en direct tu as
accepté notre invitation merci Monsieur
le Ministre tu seras avec nous
et on acceptera toujours ici tous les
courants de pensée quand il y a un
courant de pensée qui représentait par
des gens qui se posent des questions
comme à dit Fabrice Sébastien hier il se
pose des questions et ben ici ce sont
les bienvenus voilà et il y a toujours
des contradicteurs et je peux vous dire
qu'ici au tour de la table elle a très
peu qui sont d'accord avec Fabrice
division mais ils sont toujours heureux
de discuter avec lui et d'entendre ces
arguments et de lui répondre par
d'autres arguments il y a un truc quand
même qui est extraordinaire et qui
montre qu'on est quand même ce symbole
d'une époque Gabriel Attal il sait pas
de quoi on parle il était pas à
l'audience il a pas le dossier mais il a
un avis et ben c'est peut-être le
problème aujourd'hui dans ce pays c'est
que des gens qui savent rien ont un avis
sur tout
s'il vous plaît là moi je suis vachement
choquée par la vidéo qu'on vient de voir
parce que là c'est c'est tellement
méprisant alors au-delà que ce soit face
à Fabrice division bon soit si ils ont
un litige entre eux en privé pourquoi
pas mais là c'est mépriser toutes les
personnes et il y en a des millions en
France qui pensent la même chose que
Fabrice et qui suivent son courant comme
vous le voyez comment c'est venu avec la
question parce qu'on me le dit c'est
Patrick Cohen le génie Patrick Cohen
Viriat partout il a quitté France Inter
parce qu'il touchait pas chez d'argent
il a été sur Europe 1 c'était un
naufrage il est reparti la queue basse
et il est donc chez c'est à VOUS Patrick
Cohen qui a dit il vient d'être évité
dans une invité dans une certaine
émission de télé donc il nous a fait un
peu de pub et il veut pas citer le nom
Patrick Cohen voilà Patrick Cohen voilà
qui est quand même le mec qui a tout
raté dans sa carrière et qui vient
donner des leçons aux autres qui vient
donner des leçons à fabriquer des vidéos
qui vient donner des leçons à vous ici
Patrick Cohen quand même non mais c'est
rigolé c'est fou ça et moi moi je
comprends moi ça me dérange pas qu'on
rate tout mais ne donnez pas de le
il représente l'échec il vient donner
des des premiers gens Cyril le problème
c'est exactement le même problème ce
gouvernement est en échec sur tout je
veux dire et bien se permettre de donner
des leçons non non moi je parle Gabriel
Gabriel Attal effectivement on a quand
même un gouvernement qui a menti ou
français depuis deux ans et qui vient la
ramener encore mais enfin un peu
d'humidité les gars regarde Géraldine
Géraldine elle est pas d'accord avec toi
sur tout téléphone d'accord avec lui ah
mais je sais pas du tout je parle avec
Maître division je vous trouve très
habile et très malin parce que alors
vous arrivez alors moi j'ai pas assisté
à l'audience je sais pas ce qui s'est
vraiment dit quelque chose pardon donc
vous allez parler quelque chose que vous
connaissez pas Jean-Michel maire ça
commence bien non mais après vous dites
que je suis très habile et très malin
oui mais vous avez pas si c'est
l'audience vous savez pas ce que vous
avez par personne
n'était pas à l'audience c'est pourtant
il est normal
vous trouvez un compliment parce que je
vous trouve dans une énième Pirou de
victimisation on va dire qu'en fait vous
remettez une pièce dans votre Jukebox et
je pense que même cette condamnation
vous arrange d'abord je suis pas
condamné encore alors donc ce projet de
condamnation vous arrange parce que
comme ça vous pouvez dire que justement
vous avez été jugé par des avocats
promotions que c'est un pourquoi c'est
pas vrai que c'est je sais pas ils ont
signé une tribune au moment où j'étais
ici face à Manuel Valls pour dire que
tout sauf Macron ces types là signé une
tribune de soutien Emmanuel Macron
contre Marine Le Pen alors comment vous
expliquer que l'opposition ce qui
déteste Macron pourquoi Marine Le Pen ne
vous ne vous accompagne pas dans dans ce
combat pourquoi ne vous accompagne pas
dans quoi pourquoi vous êtes seul
finalement alors je suis seul
sans personne et j'ai une pétition qui a
quand même recueilli un peu plus de
20000 un peu plus de 20000 signatures
Marine Le Pen Mélenchon pourquoi ils
sont pas derrière
c'est quoi le problème peut-être que ces
gens ont autre chose à faire aujourd'hui
que s'occuper des tweets et des passages
télévisions et je les en remercie
peut-être que vu l'état de la France
j'espère que les députés de ce pays ont
fait que les avocats qui ont que ça mais
tweets vous parlez de la liberté la
liberté d'expression
en fait il paye ses prises de position
qui dérange et sa partition ATP c'est la
participation à TPMP regardez le
traitement médiatique on l'appelle même
pas Fabrice viviaux c'est l'avocat des
Antilles qui sort la faire l'avocat
chérie des antivax l'avocat vue chez
Hanouna là c'est une certaine émission
qu'on ne peut pas citer on sent que ce
sont des gens qui se bouchent le nez
parce que c'est les arrange pas que les
prises de position de Fabrice Zizo soit
dites sur des plateaux télé et ce qui
lui arrive c'est dégueulasse c'est pas
vrai
TPMP
il veut mettre TPMP il veut mettre les
chroniqueurs il veut mettre vous et du
coup
vous essayez de faire de l'humour
maladroitement mais c'est pas drôle pas
sérieux votre parole vous n'êtes pas
suffisamment stupide peut-être tenir un
tel propos sérieusement mais peut-être
non ah vous êtes suffisamment stupide
pour te dire j'en sais rien
mais Gabriel
Attal il me dit on se dit tout hein il
me dit il me le dit en face il me dit
ouais moi j'aime pas trop quand ta vie
division ou Emmanuel Macron
mais je veux dire
ici plein de fois il y a des gens il y a
des gens aussi que d'autres invités que
d'autres émissions j'aime pas je peux
leur dire
tu es suffisamment intelligent pour
savoir effectivement qui tu invites et
qui tu invites pas sans te laisser
impressionner par les positions des uns
et des autres maintenant tu imagines que
c'est pas le cas de tout le monde à la
télé et que quand Gabriel va avoir un
animateur de couple j'aime pas trop que
tu as envie de celui-là ou celui-là mais
donne ton avis moi il nous dit pas je
suis bien d'accord
tu sais aussi il donne son avis en tant
que mini moi je suis d'accord avec moi
je lui donne mon avis sur cette personne
annuler aujourd'hui dire du mal de
Macron et de tout ça veut dire quoi
important que ça malgré tout voilà
Gilles alors moi je trouve que cette
affaire division j'avais préparé un
dossier contre
et je vais vous dire quelque chose Cyril
la faire est lourde ce qu'on vous
reproche c'est grave c'est propos
grossiers vulgaires et offensants mais
la manière dont s'est déroulée
l'audience Cyril ma scandalisé parce que
cette audience Vous ne pouvez pas le
dire mettre des visions mais moi je vais
le dire c'était un règlement de compte
ultra violent mais avec des mots
grossiers offensant vulgaire contre vous
contre TPMP donc contre les gens qui
nous regardent et ça c'est dégueulasse
moi je suis jamais d'accord avec vous je
partage aucune de vos opinions quasiment
mais là la personne s'est déroulé donc
la plupart exactement mais là c'était
les bien-pensants cet ordre des avocats
qui ont fracassé Touche pas à mon poste
ils ont dit ils ont dit que les gens qui
vont regarder non mais j'ai eu des
informations que les gens qui nous
regardaient étaient débiles ils ont ils
ont cité mettre division contre dira pas
il y a eu le terme hors-durier est-ce
qu'il y a eu ce terme prononcer on a
prononcé voilà exactement mais vous vous
rendez compte c'est-à-dire qu'ils vous
ont fracassé ils ont fracassé deux
millions d'habitants
vous savez Géraldine j'ai pas besoin de
mettre division de vos conseils pour
travailler tout ce qui est là c'est des
années de boulot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est allé parler pendant un quart d'heure
il a vidé le cerveau Gilles Verdez donc
je vois que Gilles Verdez a beaucoup
tropictions donc je voulais savoir
comment ça veut dire que vous
reconnaissez qu'il est parfois plein
la répartir
moi je suis d'accord avec vous sans rien
mais là si vraiment vous reproche que
d'avoir pris la parole dans une émission
et je vais contre Géraldine pour une
fois franchement scandale parce que à
l'époque quand c'est maître Vergès de
Vergès qui s'exprime on le respecte
quand c'est sympa de vernis Vergès le
ministre de la Justice qui s'exprime on
le voilà on dit rien et parce que c'est
division on se permet et pour le coup si
c'est vraiment ce qu'on lui reproche
c'est effectivement de la liberté
d'expression il peut dire ce qu'il veut
même des conneries on va voir ce qu'on
pense à tes spectateurs dans les
téléspectateurs les téléspectateurs
et c'est donc c'est à vous qui a Twitter
voilà le tweet de Gabriel pour faire un
peu un peu de buzz et on embrasse
d'ailleurs Patrick Cohen il y a plein de
gens d'ailleurs sur Twitter qui dit
c'est vrai que c'est une il y a des gens
ils disent c'est une déchetterie c'est
le c'est vraiment un échec
la finalité c'est que si les propos de
division n'était pas aussi sulfureux
est-ce que vraiment on se souciait de
son cas et on lui reprocherait de mal
parler quoi que ce soit un problème mais
juste en fait c'est propos dérange et
que ça dérange le gouvernement et que ça
dérange tout le monde
était poursuivi pour ce qu'il a dit
Péronne était poursuivi pour ce qu'il a
dit
je l'ai dit ok à un moment donné il faut
abroger la liberté d'expression et on
termine ça va plus vite un médecin peut
pas s'exprimer sur ce qu'il a dit tu vas
arrêter est-ce que tu vas arrêter la
télé
non ça dépend allez dans les émissions
chantent je vais pas je vais arrêter oui
par exemple
[Rires]
c'est pas facile pour lui ah ok il y
avait une petite
non ce qui est important c'est de
revenir ici parce que ici c'est un vrai
lieu de débat et ici je suis désolé mais
vous représentez les Français point
parce que et c'est comme ça il y a
regarde l'émission politique sont toutes
nues à chier pour faire simple elles ont
des audiences nulle et face à la balle
l'année dernière exploser les parts
parce qu'à un moment donné tu as trouvé
quelque chose pour parler aux gens et
c'est peut-être ça c'est génial que
Darmanin Vienne merci voilà Guillaume tu
es d'accord avec ah oui je suis moi je
viens vous sucer avec lui si vous voulez
allez merci Fabrice en tout cas le
résultat est dans son âge laissez-le
voilà non à 69% 70 merci Fabrice